[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه هديه اسرائيل في يوم الطفل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العالمي
كلمات يرددها هؤلاء الاطفال وتنشرها هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه اللافت ان الاغنيه تحمل
عنوان الصداقه في اغنيه الصداقه مطالبه
بتدمير قطاع غزه والقضاء على جميع سكانه
بالكامل حتى لا يبقى اي شيء ساعات قليله
بعد ذلك حذفت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
الاغنيه عن حسابها ولم يبقى لها اثر على
المنصات الاسرائيليه عدا حساب على منصه
اكس ل صحفي امريكي ليست هذه الاغنيه نشازا
عن الكراهيه التي يصنعها الساسه
الاسرائيليون ايام قليله بعد الحرب على
غزه هذا ما قاله نتنياهو في تصريح
رسمي عليكم ان تذكروا ماذا فعل بكم
العماليق قال الكتاب المقدس ونحن نتذكر
مقاتلين الشجعان في غزه وحولها الان
العماليق في تصريحات نتنياهو هم العرب
الكنعانيون المعادون لبني اسرائيل وفق
الاصحاح الخامس من سفر صموئيل
الاول يقول الله القدير عندما خرج بنو
اسرائيل من مصر حاول عماليق منعهم من
الدخول الى كنعان ورايت ما فعله عماليق
فالان اذهب وحارب عماليق اقض عليهم قضاء
تاما هم وكل ما لهم لا تشفق عليهم اقتل
جميع الرجال والنساء والاطفال والرضع
واقتل ثيران وغنمهم وجمالهم
وحميره هذه الافكار نفسها يقدمها السفير
الاسرائيلي السابق لدى الامم المتحده كان
هذا الرجل صوت اسرائيل لست سنوات امام
العالم من الصعب للغايه لاننا نتعامل مع
مجرمين وكاذب وناس نفذوا اصعب جريمه منذ
المحرقه النازيه ونتحدث هنا عن رضع ربما
لا ينجون
بالحضانات
اجداد هؤلاء وصلوا الى ارض فلسطين قبل 75
عاما قادمين من اوروبا هذا
الظلم الوم يقتلون خمسه اطفال كل ساعه منذ
بدايه الحرب قبل 45 يوما ولا
يزالون
[موسيقى]
جيالكم ليش ما
في يا ع ارض محرو قبل اربعه اشهر من الحرب
نشرت معلمه من غزه هذا العرض على قناتها
في
[موسيقى]
يوتيوب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الشما ارض
محرو لا ندر اليوم ان كان هؤلاء على قيد
الحياه ام
لا غيري مثل صغير اعطونا السلام اعطونا
الطفر